a grieving mother makes an appeal as she
buries her son
luckman slim the publisher and activist
was assassinated a week ago
in the first high profile killing in
lebanon in years
in a message to her son's killers salma
murshak said
weapons are of no use if you want to
build a nation
look man's family says he was killed
because of his criticism of hezbollah
the mainly shia armed group he accused
of monopolizing power
and working for the interests of iran
those who see slim's killing as an
attempt to silence voices of descent
are defiant i feel that his feeling
was was targeting not him alone
but it was targeting pluralism
and diversity in the shia community
hezbollah has denied any role in the
murder and accused its opponents of
exploiting it for political gain
but for some there are facts that can't
be ignored
it happened in an area we know clearly
who controls it
in lebanon we have a history of
assassinations and
many have evaded accountability the
evidences were covered up some of the
investigators were assassinated
many activists who oppose hezbollah
believe they too are at risk
but zero fear is their message to those
who accuse them of working
for western countries he gave tools to
young generation to look at their
history
people who um who invest in
in ideology dogma i find lokman as a
[Music]
annoying and he's annoying
and that's why he was killed i think
luckman had a wide network of relations
western diplomats attended the memorial
ceremony
they added their voices to calls for a
transparent investigation
in a country where there is little trust
in a politicized judiciary
lokman slim lived in the southern
suburbs of beirut this is
his father's home and it's been here
since before the neighborhood became
a hezbollah stronghold his family says
lukman
refused to leave despite years of
threats and intimidation
public criticism of hezbollah has
recently been growing
the group still enjoys the backing of a
majority of shia muslims an estimated
one-third of lebanon's population
but supporters of luqman say he showed
there was
another voice senator al-jazeera beirut